l'événement musical avec elle la sortie
de maths de l'anthologie de france gall
30 ans de tubes 30 ans de carrière 20
millions de disques vendus en france et
une chanson totalement inédite la seule
chose qui compte
en fait un double événement après de
longues années de silence france gall
qui n'est pas apparu sur un plateau de
télévision depuis 1997 est notre invité
mais d'abord tout pour la musique
évidemment
déclaration
clara tôt
là
cette fois
non mais
ça
chacun de vous
pour atta
il faut
où
il est
les rues
ah ah
qu'ils soient rien
vimont
celui que j'ai mis dans le monde
mais bon
van rompuy devant
il a man
et en avant pour l'épaissir
comme des enfants
l'espace
je sais pas
voilà toujours qu'ils se mêlent
qu'est ce que ça vous fait revivre le je
me souviens de ton frère
j'ai la musique dans les cieux bien une
façon de mourir
une seule façon
être heureux et c'est la seule chose qui
compte
la seule chose pour soir un bon soir
c'est émouvant de voir est tellement
familier de voir défiler fait ses
chances en 30 ans de carrière alors
d'abord peut-être vous a pas vu sur un
plateau de télé nombreuses années
comment avez-vous moi j'ai très bien les
attriste je vais très bien vous voyez
d'ailleurs je vous ai vu chantonnay
suivre avec beaucoup de gourmandise
finalement le passage de ses chansons
vous sortez donc une anthologie une
anthologie de votre carrière de votre
vivant c'est pas banal comme démarche
c'est vrai que c'est assez bizarre mais
finalement c'est un moment sortir d'un
intégral c'est un moment de partage et
autant que je sois là pour le partager
on va revivre le public qui m'a suivi et
puis moi tout c'est ce parcours et et
pour moi c'est une formule bilan c'est
une forme de les transmettre à mme
héritage de musical où c'est un passage
puis un passage vers quoi en même temps
en même temps c'est un moment de partage
en même temps c'est aussi pour leur
proposer toutes ses chansons avec un son
remasterisé donc un son extraordinaire
de pouvoir écouter dans les meilleures
conditions
et aussi la troisième chose c'est que
j'ai envie d'avoir un intégral sur un
support cd alors qu'on ne sait pas dans
quelques années qu'elle sait si ça
existera est probablement plus donc il y
aura plus d'objet
je voulais mon intégral en objet je
voulais que les gens qui m'aiment est ce
cet objet chez eux mais vous en parlais
que ma comme un point de votre carrière
ou c'est un passage est ce que c'est
tourner une page et puis comment va
s'écrire la nouvelle page
est-ce que cela s'écrire en musique au
bal à tout le monde a envie de savoir
falloir sortir la boule de cristal pour
le savoir mais autant tous les cas c'est
un moment très très agréable que je
qu'on peut que je pouvait redouter parce
que j'avais peur de la nostalgie
peut-être de la tristesse en revivant
toute ma vie en fait parce que toutes
ces chansons et y est c'était c'est yann
un équilibre une montée et une
progression et ce sont ces sept des
chansons qui font
du bien réentendez est champion du fond
du mal va tout tout sauf une fois des
oui c'est vrai que je réécoute pas
qu'ils s'allient chanson qui s'appelle
bébé comme la vie bon mais je me ses
chansons elles ont été écrites pour moi
donc je les reconnais tout je me sens
bien dedans
ces deux mois dans ça parle et vous avez
donc on va vous allez passer quelques
années difficiles
qu'est ce que vous avez appris sur vous
même et bien que j'étais vraiment
quelqu'un de doué pour le bonheur et ça
oui et qu'avez vous découvert sur les
autres j'étais pas mal centrés sur moi
sur les autres je sais que les autres
ont un parcours aussi à faire chaque
personne a un parcours à faire et donc
je regarde ces parcours et beaucoup
d'indulgence
je dois dire ça vous a changé ah oui oui
oui mais ça heureusement parce que je
sais c'est normal je dirais qu est-ce
qui vous aider dans ces moments là
lecture le silence de silence oui et le
silence et le face à face
est ce ce oui c saf se retrouver
soi-même
j'ai eu une vie extraordinaire une vie
mais extrêmement riche très agitée
beaucoup de voyages une vie à 2000 à
l'heure et
c'était important de pouvoir se
retrouver dans le silence vous sont
aujourd'hui apaisées
ouais en harmonie ouais ouais qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter bien que ça
continue que ça continue comme ça je que
je sais ce que ce qui me rend heureuse
et donc je vais tâcher d'y aller et sans
quitter la musique parce que je la
musique est toujours très importante
pour moi
mais est ce que je la ferai moi-même je
ne sais pas je ne sais pas ce qui va se
passer dans l'avenir tout ce que je sais
c'est que ça va bien et que je suis
heureuse de voir vivre partager cette
anthologie avec l'objectif hameau de
cette chanson inédite de la alors vous
l'aviez totalement bio c'est comme un
trésor qu'on trouve dans un groupe mais
vous avez c'était ça a été enregistré à
l'époque de l'album babacar en 86 ou 87
et avant c'était des vinyles des 30 cm
et il y avait trop de chansons il a
fallu en enlever une j'avais proposée
celle là puisqu'elle ne ressemblait
absolument pas au reste de l'album
michel l'adoraient et il n'était pas
content mais c'est ce qu'on a fait on a
enlevé cette chanson et puis maintenant
quand la radio mais je l'avais moi je
l'avais oublié c'est vrai vous avez
ressenti quoi eh ben je me suis dit que
rien n'était perdu
en effet le formidable cette chanson
voilà elle est tout à fait elle
correspond tout à fait aux discours que
j'ai que j'ai envie d'avoir aujourd'hui
merci franz kaiser a répondu à notre
invitation merci